It doesn't seem to make much sense to have a room that is 0 square meters in
area. So I'm going to say that A of 0 equals 0 does not make sense in the
context of this story. We know that Grant definitely wants a room to exist. His
employees want to have a lot of fun. We need actual space to do that in, 0 just
doesn't really make sense. We also have A of negative 3 equals 18 meters
squared. In this first one that we marked off, neither the input nor the output
really makes sense. But in the second choice, it's a little bit trickier because
the output seems totally fine. Grant could conceivably have a room that was 18
meters squared in area. However, since x is a length, it doesn't really make
sense to plug in negative 3 for it's value. What kind of ruler could you use to
measure a negative length? So this trace doesn't really make sense either.